welcome to this video yeah this is no
blitz game this time yeah I'm glad to be
back doing some other videos ya know
that I got my vacation done I played the
GM event that I wanted to play a plate
this last week and also got my books
finished my books yeah my book is
finished just some very minor
corrections and little things to do but
the whole bark of it is done so I've got
some more time now um to to do other
things and one of this is of course
doing more videos yeah let's start I
want to definitely get to do the viewer
game so I got so many interesting games
to two show and analyzed but I guess
some of you are interested what I did in
this GM tournament and may your account
yeah I didn't do really well those of
you and maybe watched the live live
stream yesterday I finished on a minus 1
score losing two games one draw losing
two games one win only one win and rest
of it draws so not very successful and I
want to really sort of yeah finish them
I want to let's say put an end to this
event by covering it on on the channel
and then look forward to do hit to do
other things it really wasn't great what
I did did in this tournament I'm making
not a game or round by round coverage
because simply won games at the end they
weren't very interesting I when I was
basically out of contention for anything
interesting which is the GM norm of
course I was pretty much content to just
play em play quick draw against GM's
they were on paper better players anyway
and if they offer me a draw i didn't
really had any big m
addition to fight for some some rating
points there I am was glad to have some
some days of holiday then after I played
yeah myself out of any ambition let's
get going and see what happens i'm
calling this small little serious 3
powder the good the bad and the ugly one
of my favorite movies by the way and it
kind of characterizes the three groups
of games i had one good game two bad
games let's say and to really ugly games
so we're going to see those those games
in the next couple of days okay this is
the first round game I'm playing a
Spanish freedom master Eric Martinez
Ramirez younger FM in his early twenties
rated 2301 exactly yeah he went before
and this was expected I had a brief look
in the preparation and he's an e4 player
playing active open open openings on
before all of the time yeah of course I
normally go e5 but he played some things
that I didn't like so much and I was
eager to try something new so I went for
c5 and also to surprise him a little bit
which but certainly was successful he
only reckons her with the fire yeah what
did we get we get the kalashnikov
Sicilian an opening that I played a
couple of times in blitz chess but never
in a tournament game um yeah I always
liked it this is this opening it's a
Sicilian obviously and has this kind of
yeah ready-made non-symmetric
symmetrical nature so it's fighting and
on the positive note it's not one of
those Sicilians wear white is going to
get a king cytotec which I don't really
like that much so the night off or the
the classical Sicilian is not the line
for me
and also I've played this rash Nick off
quite often in in earlier years in the
90s early 2000s so I have some
experience with the position type okay
he went c4 there should be seven be
three ya b3 this line was very much in
fashion for a while in the 90s but then
it also went out of fashion bag again I
wasn't completely surprised by the movie
had played it before in a game but when
I was preparing I really had to start
from scratch because uh I mean I have
this excellent book by Tony rotella The
Killers the Syrian it is caught very
very nice book about this opening and
then look through some of the lines but
it really couldn't prepare this opening
as a whole it was a bit dicey to play it
anyway without superb acknowledge what i
did know that be 39 f6 is played and now
they normally play Bishop to d3 this is
what I remembered and yeah after Bishop
b3 I wanted to get to just play normal
boots yeah like castles castles and
maybe 97 yeah going to see hive then
maybe bishop is 6 a-6 this kind of thing
it's an interesting strategic struggle
black of course has given up control
over d5 but he's got a good foothold in
the center is got night on c5 and very
often yeah not very often but sometimes
you get in night to defy it would be
really nice long term Bishop g5 is also
of course an idea to trade off this
somewhat bad bishop yeah this was what I
reckoned with what I expected but he
played Knight to c3 and rather quickly
yeah and i really i really thought wow
is this any good and then i started to
come up or to calculate quite quite a
bit and then i went for the following
line a 69 a three and i went queen a
five this is a very direct way to try to
exploit whites whites move on
yeah those two nights they are not very
harmonious on C 3 and a 3 the c3 night
is hanging there is this threat of
course and a 3 is also potentially
vulnerable yeah after Queen 85 white
only has one move Queen d2 that's the
only move otherwise I'm just winning
material of course yeah what what else
is he supposed to do I mean let's say he
does that [ __ ] just going to I can
take the first problem or d5 that's the
second problem which shows why this
night is also vulnerable a team yeah he
really only has Queen d2 yeah and here i
came up with a very very aggressive move
which is maybe debatable but once I
started to calculate it it was too
interesting not to play and I went I
went for it I went d5 that's of course
yeah always always a great move if you
manage to play it yeah this kind of
breakthrough on the square where the
opponent is just like controlling it
perfectly as c4e for knight on c3 the
queen or d2 and still d5 is a playable
move it's quite interesting and it is a
playable but I'm not really that
convinced if if it is the best way to go
yeah so what happens now why can take
with with all kinds of moves only an in
fact there are only a one or two that
are really completely bad but let's have
a look he took with the night which is
probably the the simplest the simplest
move in comparison and let's start it
takes the first move that's interesting
yeah the the interesting point is that
after Bishop before yeah I'm training 94
but after night a1 a2 b1 this is not
really that great Knight takes bishop
takes Bishop takes and now the queen is
attacked and white gets a third piece
that's quite a lot yeah I mean three
three pieces
is quite quite something for the Queen
and he is quite well coordinated so what
does this mean Bishop before is playable
but I probably have to do something like
this 94 and now I'm threatening night to
be three taking them it's really a messy
position and I couldn't really evaluate
it on over the board but he also avoided
it is interesting it's interesting this
line at first you might think it's not
playable at all the same actually
applies for this capture we're at first
you think a way this is not going to
work at all yeah Bishop before okay but
white hands night see form and that's
not clear at all yeah Bishop takes
Knight takes bishop takes a five takes
gags and really it's just equal material
and white will be able to save his
bishop this is this is better for wide
but I have other ideas I can and this is
what I wanted to play of course I wanted
to go here with this and then Bishop
before yeah winning a crucial tempo even
this it's not totally clear 96 check
yeah and then takes on c6 free it looks
crazy but this is not a clear clear
position white have three minor pieces
and it's not so clear that I win one of
them it's it's really completely unclear
this this line yeah amazing there were
other ideas even and there also was let
me look at it where is it
yeah here after 95 actually now hit a he
took with a night and here it was
interesting here I originally only had
calculated Queen takes d2 and when we
had this position I actually thought
okay well it's not the only move
actually there are there are other ones
and for example the move Bishop before
it's quite interesting now what has to
take night takes and now I'm threatening
94 and then the double check on C to F 3
is the only move and then castles this
is a funny position White has very
little development and I get in rookie
aid with the tempo but it's very
difficult to find something concrete iam
yeah white um always can put the Queen
on c3 and let's say let's say here like
here up the eighth and maybe even a
queen III is even possible I root q1 I
don't know it's it it looks it looks
weird yeah there's some compensation but
one problem is that the dark squares are
pretty much in control by why it
sometimes but should be three is a move
if I give the check for example yeah
it's not it's not a convincing
continuation another interesting move is
not to be four by the way here there are
very very strange positions that can
rise like f3 yeah and now for example
night ft 5c takes 93 check Bishop takes
Bishop before night see for Bishop takes
Bishop takes Queen somewhere yeah let's
say yeah I don't know and this should
before I mean what I'm getting at is if
you look at this your blog is a queen up
but how happy are you in this position
yeah White has two strong minor pieces
is an excellent might and I mean
something like this is scaling somewhere
a Kalia
stranger but white has some very decent
compensation like here and then just
castles Roxy one hard to untangle yeah
okay I took on d to ultimately yeah he
it was interesting he very quickly now
took with the king sort of I mean I
wasn't totally sure what to do after
Bishop b2 actually yeah the thing is 97
is a threat and this is a really unclear
situation now maybe 2c 2d seven night
before the ideas King c6 and then
trapping this check check yeah I don't
know I have no idea what's going on in
this position it's it's kinda weird 22
stranded nights pretty unclear I don't
really know yeah i mean i also have king
e7 by the way this is also possible
night x + 90 form this is this is what i
actually had yeah in mind but it is it
is very difficult to evaluate i'm an
exchange down but i have some play of
course i have the momentum yam and very
difficult for wide to play if he does
that for example there should be six you
know and now Bishop c5 is a possibility
roop d8 i'm very well developed I'm an
exchange down but the development is is
very very nice let's say here intending
a for attending Bishop b4 i have a very
nice initiative I know it looks it looks
maybe not not that clear the Queen's are
traded and so on but blackest is very
very active if you look at it with a
computer it gives it as equal very very
young
difficult to play yeah it was an
interesting alternative this this Bishop
cakes I don't really know what he didn't
like them but he took with the king yeah
and here nice Texas was the idea kingi
form and yeah here the the key position
this is actually what I had calculated
when I went for Queen a5 p.m. I looked
up to this point and yeah it is of
course critical yeah the night is
hanging and there is 97 but the thing is
I can just play have two moves actually
Bishop f5 or porn f5 I went for a pawn
to f5 and yeah the reason is i wanted to
i thought that this is the more yeah
more fighting move in a way after Bishop
take Bishop f5 this is actually
attractive yeah Bishop c5 is a nice red
and white can absolutely not check yeah
this is leading to a complete disaster
so quite funny this position if you look
at it something like that with all the
pieces of checking the knights and
bishops now there are even some funny
funny quick checkmates a checkmate
that's quite nice I don't have that too
often so very nice attacking
possibilities but okay why does not
blundering with nice except he can take
on e7 and now the problem is that after
King takes this Bishop d3 and this nidus
is a big problem there is no way to go
this is the problem paying with check
yeah so 97's this part is the move and
here well I thought that this is
certainly okay for me but I some of
health at f5 would post in more problems
here he can play mean now not all or
move yeah it's not like it's it's it's
can do everything but like here or maybe
f3 knight back and then something like
that and then f6 I mean black is ok but
I felt I don't post to too many problems
there this is why i went for f5 again if
he wants to grab material it won't end
well jack yeah it's it's it's almost the
same thing you know like him check check
your mate even that is a maid yeah funny
very funny yeah okay he has to take on a
7am and he did that he did that quickly
the idea now was that here i can
actually take with the king and i wanted
to get this in because 94 is an
attractive-looking move or sometimes
night before um this position is okay
for white but he has to play exactly one
continuation now which is not that
difficult to find but he yeah he didn't
evaluate correctly what he played what
he should do is f3 maybe maybe i can
only speculate and didn't look at the
game um we didn't look at the game
afterwards um one reason was that the
games were played pretty late in the
evening and normally after the game the
only thing you wanted to wanted to is a
yeah maybe have a little snack or or
maybe have a beer head go to bed or
something it was just too late to do
anything maybe he was a little bit
afraid or irritated by the movie form
that that's possible yeah because it is
a bit scaring white has to take now and
this King doesn't have many squares yeah
look the aid for example would threaten
rook before
mate but after Bishop b2 king of six
threatening made again this always g4
and this will save white I mean saving
in terms of winning so maybe he was
somewhat irritated by some of those
possibilities I mean it's possible it's
possible but he should play a three I
have to go back then there's no
alternative f4 is not on and then King
f2 and this position is I think about
equal at first I was even thinking I
wear my worse here I had the bishops but
it's not a really big problem I just
have to play like King move and then I
have route 28 or something like this the
the reason why this is ok for bloggers I
have very good central control the
nights are active and his night on a
three is really a bad pizza he has to
reroute it let's say something like this
Bishop here 93 rue create this is the
kind of situation that we will get like
here and then I can go an ID for not be
41 of those moves and I think it's about
equal I can always make sure to get one
Bishop back by taking on e2 ever want
this is what he should have done but he
played F form until yes I don't know
exactly what but here he s missile
evaluated something but I didn't exploit
it to the fullest um yeah I took on f4
can of course and the King captured yeah
a g5 check that's good oops I'm sorry
check the g5 check and King to III yeah
and now now I make a mistake the the
only real mistake i think in the game um
yeah i simply i simply violated to it as
simply violated this principle of
candidate moves i was I mean to be
honest i had spent quite some time in
the earlier phase when i went for Queen
a 5 and so on but still I mean I
definitely had enough
I am black he has a fantastic move on
man fantastic a very good move that that
gives him clearly the better chances I
think it's almost winning almost winning
but it's serious I mean I didn't find it
I didn't find it um maybe maybe you can
treat this as a little exercise black to
play and get a very very clear advantage
um yeah I'll be silent a couple of
seconds here me yeah the move is rook e8
I didn't really didn't really think
about it about it i mean what i played
this route d8 yeah i was thinking okay
open file prevent Bishop b3 maybe 94 is
in 95 g4s in this kind of thing and it
didn't really look much further I
thought I like my chances after hoopty
ate and went for it but rookie aid is
much stronger the idea is simply black
wants to move the king and then he has a
monster discovery with the night it's
very very difficult for white to to play
play even even play a roof here if he
goes let's say g3 or something up
looking at their foursquare I'm going
here and what are you doing now I'm
threading this kind of thing okay here I
go here it takes a check and takes okay
you're going to get completely
annihilated here all those pieces yeah I
don't know it's very very strong this
Ruby a move the strongest defense is
Bishop b3 and here black has a great
continuation f4 check king cakes and
Bishop g4 and this is really great look
at this black has a threat here King
discoveries yeah let's say here
mate mate that's the big threat yeah so
what should why play probably Keaney
five yeah and now how does black play
Kingda seven threatening rookie five
made rookie five made King c7 okay check
or King c5 check check check mate and
made or alternatively here to threaten
bishop c8 made and it's impossible to
prevent yeah why can't I can play some
some can be cards a museum and this is
coming next with meet funnier I'm not
saying you should calculate all this
stuff when you play ruki eight but the
idea to play rook e8 key away and check
this is just very strong it didn't occur
to me it was a case where which
sometimes happens to me as sia a decent
move another then I go for it yeah and
yeah Group D 892 and 95 this was my
original idea I going for this this
thing 94 and so on went here 93 yeah
this one was an idea as well with Luke
28 I want to go see f4 check however
while the position it's not easy for y
to play it still a little bit shaky with
the king he is ok now and he played
correctly at first g3 yeah to prevent f4
that's a very logical move and I went
King to f6 but now I had spotted some of
those ideas you have rook e8 but the
main idea of King f6 is of course f4
check and this is what he completely
ignored to my surprise I was expecting I
was expecting a move like rook e1 rook
f1 like this for example after which F
form is not on of course you can take
with the rook at the end and here
there's
nothing special going on I mean I was
thinking that I can maybe take and I
know can I do be 5 i'm not quite sure
rookie aid was was a simple kind of
solution it's still a little bit easier
for black to play because these pawns
are somewhat dangerous and his king is
slightly shaky yeah I have oops I'm
sorry I have sometimes this kind of
ideas I still would prefer black in a
practical game but objectively speaking
he is okay yeah he went Bishop b2 and
this is i believe almost losing I don't
really see how he saves himself after
that effort check it's just coming yeah
and I don't know what he overlooked here
it's pretty straightforward white cannot
take I'm just taking this check and I
have Bishop g4 may be overlooked that
one I don't know Bishop g5 it keeps
everything together and rook d3s isn't
Fred this is just a piece really um you
have to be a little bit careful but it's
an extra piece yeah you went here and
now everything is coming with the temple
that's very important 92 King takes
check check and now white only has one
movie has to go to e1 snow real
alternative if he goes there I'm going
to d2 immediately so had to go there
yeah and here took a moment I wasn't
sure I only had a couple of minutes left
it's important for this tournament to
know that they play or we played 90
minutes for the whole game and 30 second
increment from move one so this is a
very quick time control in comparison to
many other classical time controls and
at this point I was down to a couple of
minutes and there had to be really quick
I mean not spend time on something
unimportant and
yeah I went King f5 I wasn't completely
sure that this is the best move but I
thought that it probably is this is
efficient it done pins of the slim and
it forces why to take on e5 and you can
argue maybe white had to take on e5
anyway so maybe a rookie move was better
for example i was thinking briefly that
something that group d 3 might be good
but i wanted to keep it simple and king
air five it threatens this check and
this check he has to take it and i saw
that this position is excellent it's a
case where the black has advantage in
space the f pawn the bishop is much
stronger than this night and yeah i'm
just attacking this is an attacking
position I didn't see any defense yet I
don't think there is any he went group
g1 which makes us a little bit easier
night before was was a little bit
tougher but I still don't think white
can can save himself i still play king
here and i have Bishop e3 coming this is
the big issue at this suspicion 103 is
this dominating this night completely
still this is tougher than then the game
in the game you went here and now it is
is it's it's even more problematic he's
now just too late with the night i have
this strong move rook t4 i'm glad that i
saw this one it makes sure that after
possible 95 undertaking with both rooks
and this is actually already a check
media can in some cases yeah like this
or if we go here yeah what did you do
actually played rook g2 ma'am yeah
Bishop h3 now was a wasn't interesting
no sorry the check first horse went here
and now Bishop h3 was even a little bit
stronger but that's it's a matter of if
you look at it in computer terms between
like plus a door plus five what I did
see is I saw a line that wins and this
is why I went for it is this is very
straightforward King has to move and now
Bishop a tree and here he actually
already resigned
it's really over I'm threatening to push
all the way through with the f porn
that's a bit much yeah I'm pushing this
pawn he has no offense the only thing
that he can try as we start with this
year checking but the king is just going
forward check and that's a gem
threatening check made if he move this
away yeah I'm having rook g5 Bishop g2
made yeah so as mentioned in this
position here here already after here
Misha better here he did he did resign
so this was a good start of this
tournament my first round um yeah a very
complicated game quite quite interesting
and unfortunately this was the only
really good game that I played in this
event but we count to that from this the
good the bad and the ugly part this was
a good part starting with that one and
the bad part is is coming I guess
tomorrow ok I hope you enjoyed this game
i guess it was was quite interesting
thanks for watching